I swear to god I don't know if you are
cheering me or the air conditioning I
honestly thought either way I'll take it
I'm happy yeah half the people here just
don't care they're just making the air
move yeah man it's great to be it what
is that you're holding up is that it
that's a cereal we have now Andy we now
have good sake
that's a comic-con cereal right that has
me on the cover it's it's just generic
cheerio no yeah no no with little bits
of asbestos at it
enjoy that they'll never catch fire yep
instead of being sweet it's bitter I'm
loving it here I'm what you're having a
great week so far at comic-con and you
guys have been amazing and we're having
such a lovely time there is so much so
much there's so much good as an Indiana
Jones just Jeff staring me right there
you were I'm trying to do comedy and
it's Indiana Jones was like this he's
looking at me like what you got I I
think he just works at the zoo
I think he does yeah he got out early
yeah I do love it here so much going on
at comic-con I'm told it by the end of
tonight's show Marvel will have released
three more spider-man movies so look for
that one against their will yeah you
know what's really cool there's a lot of
stuff happening this year at comic-con a
panel is celebrating the 90th
anniversary of Popeye
yeah pop I should appeal to Millennials
since she's covered in tattoos and has a
plant-based diet I swear on paper that
is very strong hey did you hear this in
July of course San Diego hosts comic-con
in August San Diego's gonna host
BroNYCon this is true a convention for
the male fans of My Little Pony yeah
yeah that explains San Diego's motto
start strong and sad I would like you to
pass the cereal forward please I just
want to see what this [ __ ] looks like
[Laughter]
you threw my cereal yoosh you threw
super Conan don't throw that pen at me I
like how I have no security here every
panel I go to the c-listers have like
nine guys around them with earpieces
yeah here a woman stands assaults me
with cereal and a pen nobody does
anything I was I was just about to
pounce yeah there you get you sure I'll
give it that too in the commercial we're
doing this show doing a show yeah I'll
sign it for her and
[Applause]
is there one security person here
I saw your life flashed before me when
that thing came there's some weird [ __ ]
in there the 90s were cruel